the National Rifle Association is still
silent about the death of falando
castile and this is yet more proof that
the NRA is all about gun rights except
when they're not last Friday
Geronimo Llanes a st. Anthony Minnesota
police officer was acquitted of
manslaughter in the fatal shooting of
black thirty two-year-old cafeteria
worker falando Castile in July of 2016
the officer pulled Castile over for
having a brake light out
Castillo's girlfriend and young daughter
were in the car with him the officer
asked for Castillo's license and proof
of insurance
Castile handed the officer his insurance
card then he reached down to his pants
presumably for the driver's license and
says sir I have to tell you that I do
have a firearm on me the officer starts
yelling and shoots Castile at
point-blank range the dashcam footage
was recently released we have a bit of
that stunning Castile 's gun still in
his pocket when the paramedics started
loading his dead body into the ambulance
now many gun owners heard about this and
they were up in arms falando Castile was
licensed to carry he possessed his
firearm completely legally he did the
right thing and immediately disclosed
the firearm to the officer the dashcam
footage shows that he posed no threat
this was the prototypical good guy with
a gun he said I had a gun I have a gun
and was essentially shot after saying he
had a gun
falando Castile was a black man and that
is logically being considered as to why
we might not be hearing anything from
the NRA because why else wouldn't they
be coming to his defense many gun owners
including NRA members Pat are outraged
from a gun rights perspective but the
NRA silent they usually jump right to
the defense of gun owners who have made
national news for having their rights
violated more than a day after the
shooting the NRA
put out a statement saying we will only
comment when we have more information
when all the facts are known so they
didn't defend him then left open the
possibility that it was Castillo's fault
all the facts are known now and the NRA
will not comment right now if this was a
50 60 year old white guy in a pickup
truck are we to believe that this would
have happened the same way first of all
the shooting wouldn't even happen in the
first place you know this guy would be
respected and his right to carry a
weapon the fact that he disclosed the
information to the police would be
something that he would be commended for
absolutely and then you know if he was
to be shot then of course the NRA would
have his back on the Internet
you can find tons of videos about how to
deal with the police when you are
legally carrying a firearm and he did
what all those videos recommend which is
at your first opportunity you calmly
disclose that you are carrying a firearm
many NRA members are furious about the
fact that the NRA will not come to his
defense even some right-wing
organizations are furious the police
officers actions
send the message that the Second
Amendment didn't apply to falando
Castille and apparently the the NRA
agrees here this could just as easily be
a pro cop thing the NRA makes a lot of
money training police they've had this
law enforcement division for 50 years
they hold shooting competitions for
police officers they bend over backwards
for cops they bend over backwards for
white people having their gun rights
violated and silence with falando
Castille and what does this tell us I
mean it really just confirms what we've
known for a long time the NRA is an
organization that is a PR and marketing
arm of the gun industry their sole goal
is to sell more guns every comment they
make every position they take is based
on trying to sell more guns and I guess
there's no upside to commenting on this
one yeah I mean a lot of these
right-wing organizations are ones that
will defend cops at all costs and also
defend your right to carry a weapon at
all costs and every now and then you
know they're able to weasel their way
out of this but you know in this
instance they really can it's one or the
other and when you can't choose one the
best approach is just stay silent I
guess so they are saying nothing and
they are choosing to remain silent no
doubt about it horrible horrible
and we'll see if we learn anything more
about it